komm her ich hab was aber das ist echt
krass schwer und ich glaube dass auch
bisschen gefährlich leute meine haare
sind nicht so gut aussieht das liegt an
der sonne auf jeden fall etwas klappt
jetzt willkommen beim neuen video
ich hoffe uns hört keiner bestimmten
hier irgendwie kommt mir so vor als wäre
irgendwie aber ich halo ist auch
scheißegal auf jeden fall habe ich ja
gesagt so meine freundin soll eigentlich
nicht auf youtube so alle zwei monate
haben wir gesagt eventuell deswegen
haben wir uns heute was überlegt was ihr
euch wirklich zahlreich gewünscht habt
so das war wirklich so wir haben gefragt
was soll man machen so und jeder zweite
kommentar macht doch mal die yoga
challenge die macht doch jeder
eigentlich so und dies immer witzig
damals wir herkommen
warum nicht wir sind totale yoga
expertin würde ich sagen
deswegen wollen wir auch gar nicht lange
lagern einige sachen würde ich zwar noch
kurz sagen und zwar ich hatte mit ihr
letztes wann kam das denn das letzte
video von unseres kann glaub ich letzten
donnerstag oder so am 1 bild der turm da
es ist einfach so heftig war auf jeden
fall kann das jetzt ein donnerstag
online und da ziehe ich mir halt
unangenehme fragen gestellt die waren
vielleicht nicht alle so unangenehm aber
zum teil schon und haben viel in die
kommentare geschrieben
alex du bist voll arrogant geworden und
schoss auf das habe ich nicht so
verstanden also immer wenn ich sagen ich
bin voll geil dann meine ich das echt
nicht so also ehrlich ich meine das
nicht so oder a40 ich kann doch auch
über mich selber lachen aber ich fand in
diesem video kam ich jetzt ich finde es
gibt videos wo es mehr so rüberkommt als
könnte ich auch ganz so klar das muss
jeder für sich selber entscheiden
aber gut ist halt zu finden uns einige
meinen und viele haben aber auch noch
geschrieben
ich dachte du wolltest deine freunde
nicht auf youtube klicks zu machen warum
schreibst du an meine freundin in titel
blablabla wo ich mir gedacht habe so
hell sie saß hinter der kamera und hat
mir unangenehme fragen gestellt soll ich
dann im titel schreiben mein bruder
stellt mir unangenehme fragen oder wie
jetzt wird es voll dunkel grad hallo
konto wieder hell werden sondern naja
wir wollen nicht lange lagern fangen an
mit der challenge du hast die übung noch
gar nicht gesehen
die sind auf jeden fall richtig geil und
richtig bin mal gespannt ob wir das
hinkriegen letzte wenn es euch gefällt
jetzt schon einen daumen nach oben
lasst den daumen nach oben ein stück
gefällt und jetzt muss ich erst mal die
kamera umstellen
dankeschön jetzt bin ich schon nass aber
nun also wir fangen an mit der ersten
übung bist du bereit und zwar handle
sich dabei um diese übung das ist
erstmals ganz einfach ist aber wir
probieren es aus kommen
das unternehmen habe keine kraft
ich komme mir irgendwie ein bisschen
dumpfer dabei aber gewahrt wird es wird
deutlich schwerer so dass wir auch die
nächste übung ist schon mal schwerer und
zwar das auch bitteschön mainz schaffen
wir können einfach mal testen er warte
mal was muss ich machen
also ich kann mich mal ich glaube ich
kann das nicht mal mich so hinlegen
wie soll das gehen
also ganz kurz warten wir das okay bist
du bereit für die nächste übung
das ist voll schwer für mich wir machen
ersten ja klar kann ich ganz schön
wir machen erstmal was einfach ist also
leute erst mal noch etwas einfacheres
auf die andere seite
nein
ich verstehe was ist eigentlich der sinn
von yoga wenn man sich dann soll man
sich danach besser fühlen ich kann mich
jetzt aber nicht so entspannt um ehrlich
zu sein das war richtig hältst du die
braut jetzt kommen wirklich neben vorher
hatte ich richtig respekt da hab ich
gedacht ob ich das hinbekomme jetzt muss
ich nämlich ein handstand machen
ich habe 2000 jahre später etwas anderes
oder wachleute leichte übung will ja
irgendwie scheiße ich würde sagen ich
suche jetzt so eine richtig schwere aus
und gucken wir mal auf 20 schaffen ok
komme ja ich hab was aber das ist echt
krass schwer und ich glaube dass auch
bisschen gefährlich hatte schlug ich
habe angst war er warum du kannst ja
noch meine hände nehmen
ok also voll geil eigentlich macht voll
spaß
nach ihrem alter was macht vor allem die
sonne ist genau das was jetzt im alter
ich glaube ich kommt yogalehrer werden
oder das war aber gut immerhin besser
als falsch ich würde sagen das reicht
erst mal nicht dass ich noch irgendwo
hier verletzt von uns beiden also du
kannst dich gern verletzten ich fliege
morgen den urlaub sollte das war es mit
diesem video wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann hat euch gefallen und ihr lasst
genau jetzt nach oben da schreibt man
die kommentare was ihr ganz eventuell in
zwei drei monaten von es nochmal sehen
wollen sind wir sehr gespannt drüber
mich hat es gefreut hat auf jeden fall
sehr viel spaß gemacht oder wir sehen
uns jetzt auf jeden fall sehr oft wieder
ich mache sehr viele videos die kommen
dann immer täglich so gegen 18 uhr
es kommt ja auch bald ein richtig fettes
projekt was heißt projekt also schon ein
geiles video hoffe ich halte euch auf
dem laufendem volkmer snapshot auf jeden
fall jetzt mittel ist hier kurz
eingeblendet
ich bin gerade im urlaub und ich poste
richtig geile sachen hab ich ja mehr
wollte auch nicht sagen wir zu versagen
haut rein